THE 33 YEAR OLD
PARAYKO AND SWEPT AWAY BY THE
>> THE ORIGINAL ENTRY, AS THE IN
THE OTHER SIDE OF IT ENTERING
THE
SITTING ON 99 GOALS.TUP AND
A NICE PLAY BY SCORE.
LONG PASS, WHAT A SKING
ABOUT ROBERT THOMAS IMPROVEMENT
ON THERE DOT.
THEN YOU LOSE T
DANGEROUS AREA.
>> NOW THE BLUES OFF THE
FACE-OFF WOIST
THAT PUCK UP IN THE AIR.
MCDAVID.
WITH 8/10 OF A SECONDPLAY FROM I
OUT PASS TO DRAISAITL ONE-TIMER
.
WE'LL KEEP OUR EYERON IS IN THEN
SEEMED LIKE IT TOOK FOREVER FOR
THAT PUCK TO GO TO THE NET
RIGHT BRAYDEN SCHENN.
THE BLUES WOULD LOVE TO GET
SOME HEALTHYHYT-LOOKING
PLAY IN THE OFFENSIVE ZONE, NOT
A LOT OF CYCLING
52 GAMES AND NEAL.
>> HE DIDN'TTHEY SCORE.
TARASENKO IT
SCORE.
EVEN LATER.